a selfish contestant who's only out for
herself or a Savvy competitor with her
eyes on the prize player 278 made a
surprising decision on the glass bridge
challenge and fans are outraged squid
game spoilers ahead squid game The
Challenge kicked off it run on Netflix
on November 22nd turning the dystopian
Thriller into a real world competition
show the series sees a group of 456
contestants compete in a gaunlet of
challenges in pursuit of a $456 million
prize naturally the these challenges
aren't life-threatening like those on
the real squid game but that doesn't
mean that some competitors don't treat
them as life or death scenarios take
player 278 real name Ashley who raised
some eyebrows for her actions during the
glass bridge challenge the rules of this
game are simple contestants are assigned
a number between 1 and 20 and have to
cross a bridge made of glass tiles in
the order of their number starting with
one some tiles are safe while others
will drop when stepped on resulting in
the contestant being
eliminated
oh my God so the players got together
and decided that they'd all take turns
making the First Leap onto a new tile
that way everyone had an equal chance of
making it through rather than the people
in front taking on all the risk but
player 278 who went fifth didn't go
along with the plan and refused to take
her turn making a leap of faith that
forc fan favorite player 301 Trey to
take multiple steps and inevitably fall
through to add insult to injury after
refusing to follow the plan initially
player 278 eventually did take the first
jump onto a new Square sending viewers
into conniption after watching the glass
bridge challenge play out in episodes 7
and 8 squid gain the challenge fans
hopped on social media to discuss player
278 actions and surprisingly the
majority of the comments regarding her
behavior were far from kind as one
redditor wrote imagine the lack of for S
sites that she must have by pulling the
stunt she did everyone hates her and she
still ended up having to do the the
exact same thing she was supposed to do
in the first place another redditor
couldn't believe player 278 choices
either calling her hands down the worst
person and player on the show by far in
their comment oh hell no they also
wonder why none of the other players
went out of their way to speak about the
situation expanding on that point one
person commented everyone enabled her
Trey should have stood his ground and
quit jumping and the guy behind her
shouldn't have stepped up till she fell
others brought up the fact that she only
went along with the team strategy once
doing so would benefit her a choice that
only further fed the fire against her
even though that's arguably the point of
the whole show one redditor couldn't
find any Rhyme or Reason to it writing
she went ahead anyway after Trey left
and then proceeded to make only one
guess which was the strategy agreed upon
to begin with make it make sense between
the glassbridge Fiasco and her actions
during previous challenges player 278
doesn't have the best reputation among
squid game The Challenge audiences in
fact it's no stretch to say that made
herself something of an antagonist in
their eyes but she owns up to that she
broke it down for Entertainment Weekly
saying right now I'm getting all this
backfire on social media and for some
reason everybody has gotten it in their
head that we're suddenly a team and that
everybody is playing fair but somebody
has to be the villain and it lands on me
for not taking an extra jump she also
made an interesting point regarding the
nature of the competition saying I stand
by it I would do it again I made it
across the bridge and I used what I had
to get what I want was I helping people
on the bridge probably not but it wasn't
a team effort she is not wrong the glass
bridge challenge was designed for every
player to fend for themselves after all
and there's only one winner in the end
so you could say that player 278 is the
only one embodying the true Spirit of
squid game The Challenge now I don't
know these people from a can of paint I
immediately F that clicky and I'm
irritated as
hell